all right we have a trailer from Morbius
a trailer I wasn't actually gonna do a
video one and then the end happened I
was like he's a spider-man villain slash
antihero that Sony owns the rights to
for the movies which gets logistically
complicated especially by the end of
this trail I'm trying to hold this cup
down so I guess it freaks people out
that I keep it in frame but don't ruin
the illusion in this trailer it shows he
has a blood disease he needs to cure it
so he does a scene that remarkably
reminds me of the crow city of angels
suppose a dumb ending a dumb ending to a
dumb movie let's be honest crow City of
Angels said there's actually a really
philosophical line in the crow city of
angels it's one of those remarkably deep
for the movie it's in kind of lines I
actually had that one of my tombstone
you know the one beautiful word vomit of
the gods
so now Michael Morbius is like oh I'm
super strong and then he starts mutating
into the living vampire and of course
abs because you're a medical mutant now
you gotta have abs who's thirsty so it's
exactly that it's exactly what it sounds
like and it's pretty much exactly what
it should be
it's the Wolfman in 2020 but instead of
a wolf it's a vampire opposites do
attract in plot lines and I'm gonna lie
to you have first it was kind of funny
to me that they were boasting really off
from the studio that brought you
spider-man homecoming and spider-man far
from home I was like yeah it's to do
that yeah I mean it's easy to see them
as Marvel Studios movies because they're
in the MCU but it is Sony that's true
and venom which people think I hate
venom I don't hate venom I like venom
and Eddie Brock in the movie and she
venom because if we're being honest
let's be honest but that company and the
scientist is a lame villain so Morbius
definitely reinforces a Spider Man
villains are essentially science
experiments science projects or
scientists who have gone wrong another
villain no exception here I think Jared
Leto should do a good job cuz I still
think Jared Leto is a good actor and we
have heard no reports of him sending
dead rats used condoms dildos or dead
bats to his co-workers for Morbius and
that is a pretty solid start learning
growth part of life alright I'll get to
what you want to hear that's Michael
Keaton zenit he's in the end of this
trailer which if that scene they show at
the end of this trailer with Michael
Keaton is a post-credit scene or
something in this movie I'm gonna be
really pissed to showed that in the
trailer is he Adrian Toomes is he just
Michael Keaton playing someone else in
this movie I mean that's happened that
could happen Chris Evans is Human Torch
and
in America it's possible unlikely though
because that that just makes it more
confusing and you wouldn't have him
cameo at the end of the trailer but I
imagine as Adrienne Tunes also he's not
the only one he's not the only thing
that points to spider-man there's a
picture of spider-man says murderer on
the wall but that picture of spider-man
doesn't look like spider-man homecoming
spider-man or spider-man far from home
spider-man looks a lot like Raimi
spider-man
I'm telling you soon he's just [ __ ]
with it which is the brilliant position
Sony's in no-one really knows what
spider-man's going to be in if there's
gonna be any crossover what he might
come into what things might bleed into
the MCU so they can just throw Easter
eggs at us and be like I don't know
let's keep the chatter going and here we
are I mean case in point this video
didn't really feel like doing a video on
this trailer until Michael Keaton but I
was like alright it's couple things to
say they're crazy times but exciting
times I'll say that you look at where we
were in the mid-2000s and look at now
not only do we have the infinity saga
wrap-up unfathomable to think about 15
years ago but now we're here going well
that venom movie happened and it wrapped
up and now we have a Michael Morbius
movie is Spider Man which does exist now
and is thriving cinematically is he
gonna cross over to this or is he just
gonna stay in the insanely successful
franchise he's in right now maybe both
crazy times
I just appreciate that so more base
looks to be a simple premise if we've
seen this premise a lot of times before
the scientist who's like I'm gonna do
the experiment on myself
oh I'm not innately a bad dude but now
I'm turning into a monster and now I got
to deal with that this this is not the
only spider-man villain with that arc
not the only one we've even seen on
screen so yeah it's kind of like The
Amazing Spider Man with no but you see
Michael Morbius on screen for a long
time and that looked at the end I'm like
well that that looks a lot like you it's
pretty accurate so I appreciate that
also great use of Beethoven I respect
that I said the trailer for Morbius have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you
[Music]